[موسيقى]
سياده السفير شكرا لك على المقابله وعلى
وقتك نمر الان في ذكرى الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ونود ان نعرف المزيد عن
العلاقات الروسيه البريطانيه بريطانيه
تقود مساعيه دبلوماسيه منذ بدء الحرب لكن
هذه العلاقات طويله ويمكن ان نصفها على
انها علاقه كامله تغيرت عن
متى بدات الامور تسوء بين المملكه المتحده
وروسيا
الوصيه
من الواضح انه منذ فتره طويله وفي الوقت
الراهن نتشارك في العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
لكن بنيه العلاقات برومتها قد تدمرت من
قبل المملكه المتحده في المجال السياسي
والاقتصادي ومجالات العلوم والتعليم
وغيرها السبب في ذلك يعود ان المملكه
المتحده والولايات المتحده اتخذتها قرارا
قبل فتره بان روسيا قد اضحت اقوى واكثر
عدائيه والقرار كان يرمي لتوسيع نطاق حلف
الناتو اقرب ما يمكن الى حدودنا وتحويل
اوكرانيا الى ما يشبه دوله مناهضه لروسيا
وقد تم الاستثمار في هذا العمل ماديا
وايديولوجيا على سبيل المثال شرعت المملكه
المتحده بعمليات مختلفه احداها تسمى
بالعمليه المداريه وترمي لاعداد عشرين الف
جندي اوكراني ضد روسيا وتم البدء في بناء
قاعدتين بحريتين وتم تنفيذ تجهيزات هائله
من اجل تعزيز قدرات اوكرانيا وتغيير طريقه
تفكيرها لجعلها معاديه لروسيا
بالعوده الى موضوع اوكرانيا بدات العلاقه
بين المملكه المتحده وروسيا تاخذ منحا
سيئا منذ زمن طويل وتتهم المملكه المتحده
روسيا بتسميم عميل روسي على اراضيها ولم
تكن الامور على ما يرام قبل ذلك فهل
يمكنني القول ان اوكرانيا كانت القشه الذي
قسمت ظهر البعير وان العلاقه كانت سيئه
قبل ذلك
في مطلع العام 2000 كانت العلاقه طبيعيه
لكن كما اسلفت القول عندما استمرت روسيا
في خطواتها لتصبح اكثر قوه بدا وكانها
تشكل تهديدا للهيمنه البريطانيه الامريكيه
على العالم الذي نعرفه بدات تغيير بحلول
العام 2013 تقريبا عندما تم تقديم تلك
الاتهامات الخاطئه والباطله ومنذ ذلك
الوقت ربما بدات الامور بالتدهر سريعا ثم
اندلعت شراره الاحداث في القرم والميدان
الاوروبي وانطلقت اولا من كييف كانت
ميدانا اشبه بثوره
نظرا للاطاحه بالرئيس على يد الدول
الغربيه وكل هذه التغييرات اذنت ببدء لكن
في الواقع كانت الحرب مستمره منذ العام
اذا هل كانت حربا دبلوماسيه
بسبب عمليات قصف جمباز التي بدات عام 2014
اذ اقترب الجنود الاوكرانيون من دونباز
وبداوا فعليا بقصف الناس وقتلهم
دعنا نتحدث اكثر عن الحرب الجاريه الان
كيف تقيمون دور المملكه المتحده ازاء ما
يحدث الواتساب
تلعب المملكه المتحده دورا بارزا في توفير
الاسلحه والمالي الى اوكرانيا ولكنها
وبهذا النوع من المساعدات فانها تدمر
اوكرانيا لان الاخيره اصبحت الان تعتمد
كليا على المساعدات الاجنبيه اذ لم يعد
لديها اي اقتصاد في الفتره الحاليه
وتراجعت قدراتها الصناعيه بنسبه 85% من
اجمالي الناتج المحلي واربعين بالمئه في
عدد السكان اذ يصل عدد سكان اوكرانيا
حاليا الى 21 مليون نسمه بينما كان في
السابق 45 مليونا قبل اندلاع الصراع بسبب
الحرب الروسيه
بصوره جزئيه توجه ما يصل الى اربعه ملايين
مواطن اوكراني الى روسيا وبعضهم ذهبوا الى
اوروبا الغربيه وكندا والولايات المتحده
الطبيعه الحال لا تزال هناك اعداد كبيره
من اللاجئين الذين يعتزمون الخروج وليست
الحرب الروسيه هي التي تحمي السكان
الناطقين بالروسيه في شرق اوكرانيا بل
انها العمليه الخاصه الروسيه هذا ما نحاول
القيام به وكما قلت هذا الدعم المالي الذي
تعتمد عليه اوكرانيا الان لا تستطيع
اوكرانيا وقف هذه الحرب لانها ان فعلت ذلك
فلن تتلقى المزيد من الاموال والسلاح لذا
ليس امامهم سوى الاستمرار في هذا التوجه
لا تدوم طويلا وقد مر
سلفا يصنفها على انها حرب بالوكاله بين
روسيا والغرب على اراض اوكرانيه
يمكن تصنيفها بطرق عده وبالنسبه لنا يرمى
من هذه الحرب حمايه الشعب والمواطنين
الناطقين بالروسيه في الشرق اعتقد اننا
نحقق هذا الهدف كما ان الخطوط الاماميه
باتت اكثر استقرارا تقريبا يجب علينا
تحقيق المزيد من المكاسب لان اقليم دونيسك
غير خاضع للسيطره باكمله اننا على درايه
بحقيقه انهم لن يتوقفوا عن قتل الناس وقصف
البنى التحتيه في تلك المنطقه
اذا كانت هذه عمليه خاصه فمتى سوف تنتهى
الى حين تحقيق الاهداف التي رسمت لا
استطيع التنبؤ في الوقت الحالي ما الذي قد
يحدث لكن الهدف العام هو وقف التمييز ضد
الروس وقتلهم ومن اجل حمايتهم تلك هي
الاهداف ولا بد لنا من العمل على تحقيقها
اننا نعيش في مرحله بالغه الحساسيه
والخطوره في التاريخ هل يمكن ان تصعد
الامور لتصبح حربا شامله قد لا تقتصر على
اوكرانيا يخشى من مغبه حرب واسعه النطاق
في اوروبا روسيا مستعده لذلك
[موسيقى]
لابد لنا من حل مشكله اساسيه الا وهي ان
نوقف السياسه النابعه من اوكرانيا
المعاديه لروسيا باتت اوكرانيا خطرا
حقيقيا على روسيا وتمتلك قدرات عسكريه
كبيره ولابد من تخفيض تلك القدرات نود ان
نجعل اوكرانيا بلدا طبيعيا يعيش فيه جميع
المواطنين على قدم المساواه سواء كانوا او
روسيا او اوكرانيا وكل بلد في اوروبا
متعدد جنسيات ايضا ويعيشون في سلام لكن
اوكرانيا قررت ان تغرد خارج السرب قررت
تحويل البلاد لتصبح اوكرانيا فقط ولم يعد
لنا الروس خيارات كثيره وقدره على العيش
هناك باتوا يقولون لهم علنا ان كنتم
مواطنون روس عليكم ان تذهبوا الى روسيا
اود العوده لموضوع العلاقات البريطانيه
الروسيه بريطانيا تتهم روسيا بشن هجمات
سيبرانيه وقرصنه وجميع انواع التجسس على
الاراضي البريطانيه كيف تردون على ذلك
دعنا نخرج اوكرانيا من المعادله فهذا
الامر مستمر منذ سنوات مثل التدخل في
الانتخابات ايضا
مر على وجود هنا ثلاث سنوات واقراوا كل
يوم تلك الاتهامات الباطله الفضه ونحن بكل
بساطه نحاول عدم الاكتراث بها كنا فيما
مضى نرد عليهم اما الان اشعر بانها اماءات
سياسيه لا توجد لدينا اي مصلحه او قدره
على التدخل بالشؤون البريطانيه الداخليه
كما ان التدخل الخارجي مساله محظوره بحكم
القانون عندما اسمع كل هذه الاتهامات نبدي
ردود فعل احيانا لكن في معظم الوقت لا
نفعل ذلك لانها زور وباطله ومجرد ايماءات
سياسيه
راينا على مر السنوات ان الروس كانوا
يعيشون حياه كريمه في المملكه المتحده
بمعنى انهم كانوا يمتلكون انديه رياضيه
ورعاياهم يشترون بيوتا وشقق سكنيه هل ترى
ان ذلك تغير بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
لقد تغير لا ان السياسه البريطانيه معاديه
لروسيا وهم يستهدفون الروس الذين يعيشون
هنا واسمع شكاوى من المواطنين الروس وعاد
الكثير منهم الى روسيا لانهم بكل بساطه لم
يعودوا قادرين على مزاوله الاعمال
التجاريه هنا كان هناك ما يصل الى 600
تمثيل عن الشركات التجاريه الروسيه وكلهم
رحلوا بسبب ضغوط سياسه بريطانيا العظمى
وهذه واحده من المساوئ فابريطانيا تحرم
نفسها من فرصه تطوير علاقه اجنبيه خارجيه
والنتيجه سيئه لنا وسي بريطانيا لكنها
السياسه التي انتهجتها الحكومه
اذا ما كنا لننظر الى مستقبل المملكه
المتحده الى اين نحن ذاهبون
هذا سؤال وجيه كيف سينتهي كل ذلك ما
استطيع قوله هو اننا لن نقوم باخذ زمام
المبادره فلم تكن مساله تدمير بنيه
العلاقه فكرهنا لكنني ارى باننا سوف نبقى
دوله مجاوره وفي نفس القاره روسيا لن
تختفي عن وجه الارض وسوف تنتصر بكل تاكيد
في هذا الصراع لان شتانه ما بين قدرات
روسيا واوكرانيا ندرك ان اوكرانيا تتلقى
دعما من الغرب ما يطيل امد الصراع
اوكرانيا باتت تعتمد كليا على المساعدات
لكن هذه المساعدات لن تستمر الى الابد لذا
علينا ان نعمل على انقاذ حياه جنودنا
وتحقيق اهدافنا وانا على انه عاجلا ام
اجلا سوف تسود مشاعر واقعيه او فهم واقعي
باننا نعيش في قاره واحده وانه يجب تصميم
الهندسه الاوروبيه بصوره حقيقيه وهندستها
الامنيه التي نناشد من خلالها بان تكون
تلك الدول في صف واحد دون احداث شقاق فيما
بيننا مع بقيه اوروبا
ماذا بشان محادثات السلام
نحن جاهزون في اي لحظه بدات محادثات
السلام في ابريل من العام الماضي لكن
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده قررت
بعد ذلك ان اوكرانيا يجب ان تقاتل واوقفتا
محادثات السلام بالفعل واصدر رئيس
اوكرانيا مرسوما بعدم اجراء محادثات سلام
وهذا غير مفهوم بالنسبه لنا
وسوف يرسلون طائرات مقاتله
قد دمرنا بالفعل جميع الدبابات التي كانت
في اوكرانيا من قبل ودمرنا جميع الدبابات
التي ارسلتها دول مختلفه ونحو 700 دبابه
سوفيتيه قديمه ولن نتوانى عن تدمير
الدبابات الجديده عند وصولها وكذلك
الطائرات